[Musik]
wie hat sich ihr blick auf den kirchen
verändert bei dem msv studie die fähren
seien in der vergangenheit in
deutschland zum ersten mal
2010 war ja schon diese schockartigen
muss wirklich sagen dass sie auch
persönlich sehr schockiert war sein
blick verändert
vielleicht habe ich vieles idealistisch
weiter etwas naiv gesehen als junger
priester voller idealismus haben wir das
schein und sein auch in der kirche
manchmal zu aus anderen erfüllt hätte
ich nie vermutet aber das hat mich
angetrieben und noch einmal ermutigt
jetzt auch zu handeln um es vieles zu
verändern
eine der fragen die sich stellen
anschluss an die studie ist noch die
kirche nach dem richtigen menschen
anzieht für das riester
ja wir müssen sehen ist wirklich das
evangelium das 14 verkünden haben so
anziehen dass menschen zu uns kommen die
für den ganzen dem anstehen und dafür
sollte ja auch die künste der nase umso
schockierender pass zu sehen dass das
war vielen nicht klar ist dass dürfen
nicht die bild das besser wahrnehmen
gehen er beklage erzeugen leben zu
ertragen